Elon Musk has restored a throng
abandoned counts as taking over Twitter
with a small commitment to free speech
it's also shown he has a line of his own
though conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
remains banned Kanye yay West was
reinstated then banned again for posting
a swastika inside the Star of David
Andrew Tate is back two for now anyway
he was first removed in 2017 the same
women should bear some responsibilities
victims of rape and he hasn't exactly
been shy since his reprieve let's take a
look
Genghis Khan had endless women and 200
children as a reward for Conquest he
tweeted on the most searched man on the
planet I've conquered Earth on the
highest status mail on the planet
females do not expect loyalty from me
they only expect that of lesser men
then there was this imagine having less
than 10 children because you're a
who doesn't have four wives genetic
failures finally if a girl follows me
and she's hot and I see a single picture
of it a private jet it's block women
can't afford Jets women are all brokies
why are you flying around on some man's
jet you should have been a virgin when I
met you Haram all right Andrew Tate now
you're you're getting very near the
knuckle with some of those tweets am I
you tell me I don't think so I think
people can understand they're
semi-satirical I think people can
understand you mean them as jokes or do
you mean them don't they don't mean them
as jokes I mean they're a overall public
commentary and observation I do mean
what I say if I were to see a girl on a
private plane on Instagram for example I
would assume that a man put her on that
private plane I would not assume she
bought it herself well if it was perhaps
that makes me misogynistic what if it
was Ariana Grande or Beyonce well that's
slightly different isn't it why because
they're famous and very rich yeah of
course and they're famous and very rich
if I saw well if I saw a 19 year old
girl from Moldova where the average wage
is 200 a month and she was on a private
jet I would assume that with the balance
of probabilities considering I'm an
adult is very likely because of her
beauty a man has put her on that private
plane yes if that makes me misogynistic
instead of just perspicacious enough to
understand how the world works so be it
I'm a realist should you be such a
generalist about these things well you
have to be a generalist when you're
looking for in the balance of
probabilities and trying to find balance
in the world you have to be a generalist
in general if I stroke a lion it's gonna
bite my hand in general there might be a
nice one but I don't want to find out so
that's how the world Works you've
praised the Taliban in the past would
you do so again tonight the world is not
black and white the world is gray it's
very difficult to sit and make black and
white assumptions about anything to sit
and say that the Taliban are completely
and utterly evil and we're completely
good as you just discussed with the
moral High Ground I believe that the
Taliban bring law and order it may not
be Law and Order we like but it's a form
of Law and Order and humans try usually
gravitate what about less treatment in
women only tonight only tonight they
have banned any women from going to
University fantastic let's get the
feminists to go and teach them a lesson
the feminists are so tough and they
stand up and say they can do anything a
man can do let's arm them up and send
them to Afghanistan I'm sure they'll fix
it yeah but it's it's not it's a it's a
serious matter isn't it that women don't
that's education and that's a very
serious answer if women are just as
capable as men in terms of combat like
feminists pretend they are they can go
over there and they can deal with a lot
of women do go to combat well exactly so
they can go deal the talibans nothing to
do with me they can stand up and fight
for their own right surely you wouldn't
defend the Taliban Banning women from
University it's saying it's nothing to
do with me Pierce it's absolutely
nothing what about the Afghan women it's
nothing to do with me on any level you
don't have a view I have a view my view
is that people naturally gravitate
towards Law and Order and if you didn't
have the Taliban you'd have different
Warlords operating in lawlessness and
there would be no way to prevent your
store your Market stall getting
completely robbed by someone with an
AK-47 and people are going to gravitate
towards a form of Law and Order America
left they left a power vacuum and the
power vacuum is now full well I don't
disagree with that okay well I do think
I do think the Banning of Women's
University in Afghanistan is utterly
horrific and I think the feminists are
going to arm themselves they're going to
show us that they can do anything a man
can do they're going to go over there to
combat they're going to teach child of
adolescents why can't you just say on
that you know what it's completely wrong
because it's not my point it's I don't
understand but it makes you mean it
makes me think it'll make your critics
think that you don't think it's wrong
they could ban all men they could ban
all sure but they're not they're only
Banning women correct they could ban all
short people they could ban all people
with long hair and not if it's anything
to do with me so they can do whatever
they want I'm not gonna go to war with
the Taliban but you've just literally
spent an impassioned first segment
comparing the way for example Dubai
handles Law and Order correct to this
country correct so you do Express views
about different laws absolutely both
places so when I put to a law that
basically bans women from being educated
it's not why is it a problem for you to
say you know what it's wrong there are
both places I've resided in to buy
London so I have personal experience I
can give my personal opinion but like I
said there's absolutely nothing to do
with me with what the Taliban decide to
do inside of Afghanistan and they decide
that's the most prudent way to run their
society then we have two choices we can
either go over there and start another
war that we shouldn't be involved in and
waste a bunch of life or we can sit and
say it's up to them they should govern
themselves there are people we're no
better than them and they've decided to
live their lives a particular way and
that's how they're going to live it like
I said if feminists are very upset and
they're very disgusted by the fact that
in Afghanistan women cannot go to school
I've been told repeatedly by feminists
that they're just capable as men in all
Realms and I expect them to arm
themselves and fly over to Afghanistan
and fix it like a lot of women have done
in combat I'm good congratulations go
fight
well this is the thing that's very
interesting because when you talk about
ideas it's not even just about
Afghanistan and feminism you talk about
ideas they must all be defended at some
point there has to come down to violence
the world is backed by violence nobody
wants to talk about this it doesn't
matter what it is if you have a
disagreement between two parties
eventually if the disagreement continues
it ends up in violence feminism is
defended by men men stand up and defend
feminism not feminists themselves
because they're incapable of violence
and we're in a situation now where
you're saying that we should send men to
go and fight for feminism why it's not a
man's
problems I think well hey I think men
can be feminists too because if feminism
believes in equality for women
I don't agree with radical feminists who
hate men right they do to me the radical
anything to me is a bad thing yeah and I
think most feminism in the west
currently is radical
well some of it is no question
absolutely but that's my point my point
is that with the Taliban are going to do
whatever the Taliban decide to do if I'm
going to fly over to another country I
will respect their laws and customs it's
not my job to come along and tell other
people how to live I don't believe I
have a moral High Ground in that degree
and if people are genuinely upset and
disgusted by it the bottom line and most
disagreements on the earth is violence
people who feel like they should go and
fix it then fix it with violence then it
can be the feminists who feel so
outraged by it but it's funny they don't
comment on these subjects feminists they
seem to instead attack the Western male
for some reason you deleted a video in
which you praised Isis why I don't know
which video you're talking about in
particular it might have been a video
from a long time ago but in general I
understand that like I said the world is
not black and white the world is gray
areas and Western imperialism as a whole
has been causing more problems than it's
ever fixed and it's disgusting and I
don't know the exact video You're
referencing but sometimes when an
underdog destroys a western imperialist
I have a degree of
I wouldn't say satisfaction but
everything satisfaction no but there's
there's certainly a degree of the way
Isis I don't know the particular I don't
know about the particular video we're
talking about Isis were one of the most
deadly Terror groups in the world
absolutely they committed a series of
appalling atrocities sure killing
innocent people left yeah how could you
possibly have satisfaction well if it's
the video I'm recollecting if it's the
video we're talking about it's about the
fact that I believe that Isis was funded
by the Western created by the West in
the first place and it wasn't a degree
of satisfaction like I'm happy Isis
exists it was a commentary on the world
well here's what you said Isis are the
real Muslims because I assist exactly
what the book says kill everyone is not
a Muslim and chop people's heads off and
set them on fire and be raging lunatics
but all the other Muslims go they're not
real Muslims because I read the book and
ignore those parts well then you're not
an effing Muslim because you're ignoring
the effing book
that's an interesting that's an
interesting point you've just raised
because I am now Islamic and it's it's
funny because I used to be an atheist
and when you're an atheist you believe
that religion causes more problems than
it fixes and then you come to a
realization and you start to learn the
truth of yourself and the truth of God
and you realize that religion is
actually the cure for most of the
problems in the world and godlessness is
the problem in the world so that is
something I will apologize for to me I
was wrong about because I was atheistic
and now as a Muslim I understand that's
absolutely not the case if that's the
particular video you're talking about
then then well that's really interesting
so you you regret saying that yeah
because you learn and you grow and you
evolve as I said at the time I believed
it because I didn't believe in God at
the time it was a very long time ago
it's actually kind of a testament to you
peers you managed to find the oldest
possible videos of me that have ever
existed but at the time I was atheistic
well no I was curious because you have
recently converted to Islam correct so
these questions are thinking pertinent
to your conversion absolutely as to what
you actually believe as a practicing
Muslim now uh yeah I believe that Islam
is beautiful I believe it's the last
True Religion on Earth it's certainly
the last respected religion on Earth and
I felt differently inside since I've
converted and I think it has the
solutions to a lot of the problems we're
facing in the world today
that particular video was once again
satirical a lot of people watching this
would not have seen it they would not
seen the joke element of it it's fine it
but it's not funny though well you know
it's like most of the time as we
discussed in our first interview with me
things are taken out of context short
form etc etc but
all in all you could say the same things
about Christians if you were to read the
Old Testament and say stick to the Old
Testament you'd kill anyone who works on
a Sunday so it's not applicable to you
wouldn't countenance violence say again
you don't countenance violence I
absolutely do not countenance violence
when I was talking about violence being
the bottom line salute the bottom line
decider between
disagreeing points of view it's not I'm
calling for violence I'm just making a
commentary on how the world genuinely
functions but when you use a word like
satisfaction
you understand that people will watch
that and think how can you possibly find
any form of terrorism satisfying I don't
find any form of terrorism satisfying I
don't find Western terrorism satisfying
either I don't think it's satisfying
that we managed to find five hundred
thousand dollars per bomb to drop on
some farmer who makes four dollars a day
under the name of freedom and and we
can't seem to pay our nurses enough to
do their jobs I don't find any kind of
terrorism and it's actually very
interesting you talk about the world
terrorism terrorist and freedom fighter
good guy and bad guy all of this is
subjective there are people who believe
that the west of the biggest terrorists
on the Earth are people who believe that
America causes more Wars than anyone
else and they've killed more people than
anyone else and there's people who
believe the absolute opposite so once
again it depends who you're talking to
it's a subjective conversation there's
no black and white in the world there's
areas of gray and that's how it is so I
thought you were talking about another
video where I was saying that Isis is
standing up and fighting for what they
believe in I'm not saying what they
believe in is right but that's what they
were fighting for at the time and it was
a completely different video than the
one you were actually referencing but
you would condemn them now I don't
condemn anybody doing anything bad to
anybody I I'm not a person out here with
a criminal record I don't hurt anyone I
just spent my first
segment on this show talking about how I
believe in Law and Order and how
important that is I think people can
operate inside of their lives safely and
walk around man woman child can walk
around in safety in any City they live
in how that Law and Order is constructed
is not my
jurisdiction I'm not in charge of the
Law and Order of of Afghanistan
Tajikistan Kyrgyzstan Afghanistan
Kazakhstan any of them there's nothing
to do with me